[Musica]
oggi voglio raccontarvi come nasce un
costume e delle strade che si possono
percorrere per realizzarlo
uno spettacolo è un sodalizio artistico
tra regista scenografo costumista datore
luci e musiche
tutti questi ingranaggi devono
funzionare in un modo armonioso
perché uno spettacolo è un sogno
realizzato all'inizio di ogni produzione
instaura un rapporto strettissimo con il
costumista insieme lui tramite i suoi
bozzetti esprimerà la sua idea e insieme
partiremo per una lunghissima
campionatura è un lavoro faticosissimo
perché la campionatura vuol dire a
ricercare le stoffe le materie migliori
per realizzare i costumi spesso non si
trovano nelle stoffe coi colori giusti e
neanche le materie
allora cosa si fa si saranno delle prove
colore delle prove di elaborazione per
arrivare il più vicino ad oggetto mi
voglio fare un esempio così forse sarò
più chiaro per donne gelose di giorgio
sangati coi costumi di gianluca sbicca
d'ispirazione è stata questa il mondo
nuovo di tiepolo dopo l'ispirazione è
arrivato il bozzetto ce la fa questo qua
vedete è il bozzetto le tele bianche
sono le campionature e vi tele colorate
sono le prove colore perché non avevamo
le materie col colore giusto
una volta fatto questo passaggio si
arriva al costume come potete vedere c'è
armonia fra tutto e per questo vi voglio
leggere una lettera che è stata scritta
nel 1162 da giorgio strehler fondatore
del picco del piccolo teatro luciano
damiani scenografo e costumista che ha
lavorato spesso con lui questa lettera
mi dice che la funzione del costume è
fondamentale per la costruzione del
personaggio nasce da una serie di
reazioni a catena tra costume e attore
tra un gesto travolta tra gente scusate
ma l'emozione vate sta uccidendo fidate
grazie grazie nasce da una serie di
reazioni a catena tra costumi attore tra
gesto e particolare del costume una
manica troppo larga costretta troppo
lunga troppo corta può richiedere
l'attore un cambiamento di atteggiamento
può modificare la proiezione scenica del
personaggio e allora preparati a
supportare insieme a me
ancora una volta l'accusa di essere un
perfezionista di spostare un bottone di
pochi millimetri per tre volte per
follia di considerare maniacalmente uno
scarto di centimetri di stoffa di
lottare per una forma modificarla a
ragion veduta
due giorni dopo il nostro
perfezionamento il nostro perfezionismo
ha un nome e lo spirito di ricerca che
ci ha insegnato il nostro galileo per
arrivare quello che vi sta scrivendo
quello che spiegando e farete che pacca
mente damiani era uno scenografo vedere
un costumista e per lui arrivare al
costume era un passaggio covi ho fatto
vedere come sono stati realizzati
costumi finiti ma prima di arrivare a
questo
ed è quello che è scritto può anche
nella lettera bisogna ci vuole una
tagliatrice che è un elemento
fondamentale che ci aiuta a realizzare i
costumi soprattutto vedere un costume
che ha un di un bozzetto e piatto invece
un costume una forma e allora da
tagliatrice porta fuori estrapola dal
disegno il costume veda una forma e una
volta che abbiamo imparato una volta che
abbiamo le stoffe abbiamo modelli ma
succede una squadra formidabile di sarte
assemblee costumi assemblee costumi che
vengono provati sull'attore sull'attore
perché dovete sapere una cosa
come scrive questa lettera un costume
per un attore è come la sua seconda
pelle ea proporre a riguardo questo vi
posso dire che per me è stata veramente
una fortuna state veramente un'immensa
fortuna entrare a far parte del piccolo
teatro di milano in giovane età e
soprattutto di poter partecipare al
poter partecipare alle prove con
strehler era sarà in teatro era emozione
era magia ci veniva praticamente
insegnato perché il personaggio doveva
fare in quel modo perché le lucido non
essere così perché le scene i movimenti
era una scuola era una scuola di vita è
una scuola di teatro e soprattutto tutti
partecipavano alle prove dall'impiegato
al tecnico di palcoscenico come avete
visto la saltata ho sbagliato non è
proprio il mio mestiere parlare in
pubblico grazie baffetti troppo buoni
guarda ho avuto un immensa fortuna di
lavorare con luciano damiani e di fare
molti spettacoli e praticamente in lui
ci ha insegnato e ci ha trasmesso la
materia il valore della materia
lui è veramente l'uomo che è riuscito a
far volare la materia nel modo più
semplice spettacolare che si potesse
fare questo che vedete è ariel nella
gara tempesta si narra con questo
spettacolo nella tempesta e gli ordini
nella famosissima tempesti giorgio
strehler
si narra che il pubblico come voi in
sala all'inizio dello spettacolo adesso
il mal di mare perché c'erano
dei lievi impalpabili dipinti a 11 da
luciano damiani che si muovevano con dei
mini con delle luci e dei musicisti in
sala e riuscivano a ricreare
perfettamente la tempesta la stessa
materia la stessa seta veniva utilizzata
anche per il costume di arie e voglio
far vedere questa cosa un attimo non
parte rinviare il video non parte
[Musica]
vedete avete visto tanti tanta
leggerezza e dietro con la leggerezza
vi posso assicurare che c'è fatica
studio e ore e ore di ricerca questo
abito nascondeva un corsetto dipende
dove veniva applicata una placca di
metallo con un anello quell'anello
veniva cantato una fune che da undici
metri cari rava giulia lazzarini e c'era
un macchinista che muoveva con sapienza
e con leggerezza giulia e queste vi
posso dire che era veramente armonia
all'unisono tra tecnico attore costume
scene e luci
era tutto meraviglioso nello post
se avete l'occasione di andare a vedere
la tempesta il video guardatela e potete
veramente capire queste parole questo
volo è talmente è stato utilizzato molti
anni più dopo da giorgio strehler anche
per il faust e il tessuto con cui è
stato fatto questo costo questo
spettacolo e non solo
ancora oggi viene chiamato velo tempesta
se voi andate da qualsiasi fornitore è
chiamato il velo tempesta sappiate che è
il velo della tempesta di strehler per
un altro grande spettacolo sempre di
giorgio strehler e luciano damiani
abbiamo lavorato in immense stanze
questa sono io
venti anni del front a tre e queste
stanze erano ricoperte
di figurini ed erano tutti in scala 1 1
ed erano maniera erano maniacalmente
dettagliati perfino la sola era
disegnata ed era fatta a mano invece per
questo personaggio che erano i pescatori
i balconi che vedete erano fatti in
feltro di lana utilizzato ancora oggi
nell'edilizia industriale erano spalmati
con una pasta grigia che ancora oggi che
ancora oggi
no non ancora oggi sposate che veniva
utilizzata nel passato per ricoprire
cariche i cavi telefonici della vecchia
compagnia telefonica della sip
alla fine il maestro damiani dava delle
sgrassate di colore utilizzando della
vernice per le carrozzerie
oggi vi posso assicurare che tutto
questo sarebbe rigorosamente fuori legge
però a quei tempi si poteva fare era
arte per il primo spettacolo che ho
servito come capo sarta piccolo teatro è
stata la trilogia della villeggiatura
con il co con la regia di toni servillo
e coi costumi di ortensia de francesco
per realizzare questi costumi dei mari
acer delle tre protagoniste ci sono
voluti i giorni e giorni di ricerca o
non trovavamo la materia giusta o non
trovammo la stoffa giusta o non
trovavamo la lucentezza giusta sapevamo
come vedete nella foto che era
illuminata da una luce da luce di agosto
disperate prese dalla disperazione ci è
venuta l'idea geniale perché non
chiamare un caro amico del piccolo
teatro
abbiamo chiamato carlo bergère che mi ha
donato la stoffa giusta quella che ti fa
dire sì è lei e soprattutto che mi ha
fatto risparmiare mi ha fatto restare
nel budget perché la cosa importante
oggi come oggi è anche per il teatro per
i spettacoli arrestare nel budget
questo qua è il terzo è il terzo marian
invece per abbiamo ci sono molteplici
modi di raggiungere la leggerezza per
franca squarciapino oscar per il cinema
la leggerezza è una cosa di ricerca
continua di sovrapposizione della
materia di di club di campione di colori
di ricami di cose nel suo repertorio
tutto è leggero spesso è anche in panne
pagine per fare per realizzare questi
costumi
abbiamo fatto un infinità di
campionature perché lavorare con lei è
leggero perché non si può imporre il
tempo anche se io come capo sarta ho
bisogno di far tagliare i costumi e ogni
tanto magari dico franca decidiamo dai e
perché è invece con lei
bisogna avere la pazienza
il tempo si ferma però sai come vedete
in questa foto che quello che sarà in
scena sarà leggero sarà stupendo invece
per questo spettacolo qua per la santa
giovanna dei macelli con la regia di
luca ronconi e con i costumi gianluca
sbicca e il regista ci ha dato come
ispirazione ci ha dato questo e
l'estrattore americano di norman
rockwell lo spettacolo parlava della
grande crisi del 29 in america e le
indicazioni del regista erano poi di
arrivare il più possibile vicino ai suoi
disegni
però dopo giorni e giorni di dipingendo
mentre metri di stoffa per raggiungere i
suoi disegni
non siamo riusciti abbiamo sbagliato non
era la strada giusta
e allora in quei casi che fa i cambi
strada cambi strada e cosa abbiamo
campionato delle stoffe morbide delle
stoffe di cashmere e così abbiamo fatto
tutti i poveri della santa giovanna e
non solo in cashmere di armani
molti anni prima era già successo con
strehler e con un'altra icona con sel e
la sua costumista luisa spinatelli se
vuoi fare i poveri resti lì di seta e
allora anche in quel caso di tutte le
camicie dei fan del dei popolani del
fuori posta fatti di seta tessuti nobili
per vestire poveri in dieci è questo qua
infatti sono i nobili e sono i poveri
della santa giovanna casi invece per la
famiglia addams di antonio marras che è
uno stilista lo conoscete che è un
artista e che ha anche un costumista ci
ha fatto realizzare costumi usando i
materiali più impensabili vinili
classiche incrostazioni pizzi
ma soprattutto ci ha fatto utilizzare
una marea di swarovski attaccati
uno a uno e stato un lavoro pazzesco ne
avremo attaccati più di 10.000
chiaramente non è uno scherzo e se li
farò vedere davvero attaccati più di
10.000 1 1 ed è stato un lavoro pazzesco
bellissimo ma forse soltanto dei pazzi
come noi avrebbero potuto fare questo ai
paesi passano alla lavorazione vedete
tutti quei verbi ci sono tutti swarovski
anche questa è questa qua e la faccia di
gianluca l'assistente di marras che mi
chiede pietà
basta perché io sono dietro gli dico no
spostano un po più su ma forse un po più
giù forse è meglio di là e mi chiede
veramente città richiede adesso fino
adesso abbiamo parlato di costumi
adesso vi voglio parlare di un altra
cosa una all'inizio vi ho raccontato vi
ho detto quanto è importante che lo
spettacolo ci sia armonia
perché uno spettacolo è una catena
perfetta perché uno spettacolo un sogno
realizzato
e quindi questo spettacolo poi
rappresenta l'armonia secondo me
all'unisono e del suo di sea di bogut
con i costumi di accettava sony
guardate non ci sono parole
e bello avete capito che per la una
sartoria teatrale la materia è
fondamentale e per renderla unica e
sublime
abbiamo bisogno di sperimentare abbiamo
bisogno di lavorare di cercare è un
percorso difficile è un persona corso
lungo che ti dà tanta soddisfazione ti
chiede anche in cambio tanto sacrificio
è un lavoro solo che si può fare se hai
passione
sennò è meglio lasciare perdere e posso
dirvi un'altra cosa
l'emozione più bella per me e quando si
impara si riapre tutto funziona è
perfetto e sai di aver realizzato un
sogno ora ritorno qui dietro alle quinte
grazie
roberta
scusate ma l'emozione fa veramente
brutti scherzi però è detto tutto col
cuore
grazie mille roberta mangano grosse
attenzione vola via e vola via